but anyways you ready to go let's do it
baby
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your
absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen as you
know we got to sing a mic it's a little
hot so don't hold it too close uh but
you know you've been here before let's
see what you got this is adam ray
everybody
[Music]
wow
[Music]
come on
slap it down put your shoes on
[Music]
wow
[Music]
i thought she was going back
i want to thank liquid iv for sponsoring
this episode grab your favorite liquid
iv flavors nationwide at walmart or you
can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use code griffin at
checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you get your better hydration
today using promo code griffin at liquid
iv.com okay well we did it so good
so good moving with griffin and welcome
to the program once again for the second
time i believe actually third because i
think third but but but only two you
aired because you were like literally my
first guest when i when i stopped doing
it at all things comedy and it was like
a weird i didn't have it all set up good
yet yeah then you came back and we did
it right that's right actually i
actually aired that episode too so this
is third [ __ ]
but it just was like i don't know weird
stuff but anyways welcome back to the
program mr adam ray thanks for having me
uh long time listener first time caller
first time caller
people uh that's one of those like
staple like i don't know where that joke
falls into the category of like
do you have like non-comic friends that
say things that they that you go oh that
you've heard that a bunch but now you
use that as like your thing because you
don't have your because you're not a
comedian and you don't know how to like
or come up with your own style or it's
just like whatever's hot at the moment
like remember when everybody was going
we're not doing that anymore
you know remember that they didn't did
you just kind of like okay yeah yeah all
right man yeah or uh yeah nice yeah or
wouldn't it well national was huge
yeah like when that's not huge uh and
shout out to our good buddy uh aristotle
who was like you know come on man which
is like
and came out of the gate firing with
that sketch yeah yeah so he got that
really funny sketch and now people are
doing that you know they're going
they're going to again so with once
again you know whatever
or some kid yeah that's all you want on
snl i feel like it's a quotable
character yeah the church lady yeah you
know just those ones or even like if you
go to like a uh in living color you know
the the the the snap the whatever
whatever those oh men on film men on
film uh you know all that kind of stuff
where you just go you know homie the
clown homie don't play that everybody
was doing that kind of stuff dude i saw
damon wayans at the haha um when they
were going to bring back living color
working out characters it was [ __ ]
they should have just taped that and put
it on dude it was so good yeah the guy
is just so funny and it was like all
modern time like his men on film reviews
were about
like film it was just like the
characters just uh withstand i don't
know the test of time i don't know if
men on film today would work
why i ain't just prepared people are so
sensitive yeah so i guess yeah he did
this one character he's workshopping
where it was a pimp reading bedtime
stories to kids no it wouldn't work
dude it was so funny he was like
dude he was just like and you got to get
the money from the so i slapped that
[ __ ] anyway cannot get up
it's just you know what i'm saying it
was yeah there would be a thing about
kids it'd be a whole thing about what a
bum or two but i don't feel truly i mean
somebody literally just asked me this
yesterday um a non-comic friend where
they're just like it's got to be tough i
hate by the way when people start like
they always they already want to dig a
hole for you yeah yeah yeah yeah like
it's got to be tough even how do you
even be funny anymore and you're like
okay
you're right man yeah you know what
yeah i think i'm going to retire tonight
yeah thank you thanks for [ __ ]
opening my eyes to how yeah yeah it's
tough i mean it's not i mean it's like
you know let's not even talk about this
a lot right you know just just let's
give it like 30 seconds of just being
like you know it's just well i want to
know is this mr potato head or mrs
potato head yeah oh here you go no
it's they
actually rick glassman gave me that
podcast yeah even that i don't know it's
like i don't
you i i think are more um and you know
you were pushing me delicate at the
wedding
uh even though i have to worry about
being people being sensitive more than
you is what i think you're trying to say
because you you don't take chances yeah
i mean look right now i think the stuff
i'm talking about in the last few nights
i'm trying to and you were even pushing
me uh at the wedding in cabo at divine's
wedding uh just some things some stories
i was telling where you were like that's
the [ __ ] to get into you got to talk
about battle man
yeah you do i see that you're like that
was funny you made this real [ __ ]
relatable and funny and you were
connected to it and i just need to get
my head wrapped around that that's
interesting you know what i really think
it is though is like people don't know
why they're funny
like that is
the that's the hardest thing to to like
have a grasp of like when you know why
you're funny uh or or just even have an
idea of like people are gonna laugh at
you when you do or say this this way
that is like when you when you
understand your point of view and that
kind of stuff and you just don't know it
yet you know right now you're still
about like
this these
these things are funny to me i say these
things in a funny way but you know i
think this is funny how i'm saying this
as opposed to like why do people laugh
at adam ray and once you figure that out
like it's like for me when i used to
coach basketball you know and i'd be on
the sideline you know and i'd be yelling
at the kids the crowd's laughing
you know
the crowd would be laughing at me i'm
like i'm doing a show i'm legit mad at
these kids you're not tr nothing about
nothing about what i'm saying in this
moment is trying to be funny you're not
trying to make the parents did you even
recognize that that was an audience no
because at that time i was just i wasn't
even really doing comedy at the time i
just knew you know i was working this
was my job you know so i was like i just
was like i'm mad at these kids that
people are laughing
but it clicked in me i was like i i you
know because i would say things like are
you point shaving you know you know what
i mean
well you're also blessed with an amazing
you know uh
voice timing delivery i understand but
the thing is though it's
but you when you recognize the formula
so i know why do you think they were
laughing oh because i it's just
my anger my whatever that is the way
whatever is coming out on the register
of my voice and some of these things
you're saying it's funny yeah so once i
recognize that so i know my brand i
complain about stuff yeah i [ __ ] about
stuff because people laugh at that some
people are like what are you always
complaining and then i just want to
punch them in the face because i'm like
i'm a [ __ ] performer [ __ ] this is
this is funny to a lot of people and
once you yeah and once you recognize the
fuel to your fire it's like i need to
maximize that and continue to flex that
muscle even when i came into your place
you know and we're looking at the
halloween decorations uh that rage put
up you immediately just started like
going into
you know what will probably be a bit at
some point yeah yeah about that and it
was like and i immediately start
laughing and but i think
do you think people need to know you and
have a little bit of connection to to
think that that
because for me it's like i i almost
expected at some point there's gonna be
something that he's gonna start picking
apart that's gonna be frustrating
whether it's frustrating at a level 10
or level two
there's some some but there's other
factors that go into it and part of the
factors is how you look how you talk
yeah the thing you know i'm already
funny you know i already get that so so
i already have that going in right you
know what i mean so it's like that's
fine so it's a certain stage presence
and all that kind of stuff but that's
been you know that's been cultivated
over time right and i'm saying this but
i feel like you asking that question is
saying thinking that oh
like they don't know me so how can i
talk about personal stuff they're not
gonna get it yeah i'm telling you that's
[ __ ] yeah it's like think of like
when you watch a a sitcom a pilot for
the first time you know there's things
you can infer there's things that like
you know you know what i mean like with
the story particular story you were
talking about i even remember it being
like you know you know it's like you you
told a whole story and you had subtext
you didn't even realize it so you were
you know single your mom was a single
mom you were you know you were the kid
and then your mom was dating people and
and then this was like the relationship
you had with each guy that came into the
life you know and you were you were also
jealous of these guys and you were
sabotaging the situation yeah bro i got
all that just from how you told the
story wow so what i'm telling you is
like you need to recognize that that's
enough it's enough yeah you know what
i'm saying yeah it's just listen man
it's just it's like it's like you can't
get it from me you're not gonna have an
aha from me it's just gonna be like
you'll feel it you'll be like i'm gonna
talk about i went to exxonmobil and this
happened and the way you can when you
find your thing then you're going to see
oh people are laughing at me because of
they're with me on this story you know
not everybody likes it you know but
there's a lot of people like that you
got larry the cable guy even theo vaughn
right now he he found his thing about
telling these like you know
are they true you know are they lies but
it doesn't matter who knows he's created
a universe but people want to hear them
people want to hear regardless i don't
think they care if they're true or not
right and also maybe that's part of the
like you know uh clickbait afterwards to
be like there's there could be message
boards of people being like
trying to fact check some of these
stories did you really have a neighbor
named barnabas you know yeah yeah yeah
um whatever it is that's what i'm saying
i did start talking last night i think
you'll appreciate this i'm not gonna do
the bit but the premise of this bit
about seeing mrs doubtfire uh two weeks
so my folks when they split two weeks
later
my buddy's dad took uh my buddy myself
and a couple pals to see mrs doubtfire
for his birthday it was like let's go
see a movie and then let's go like get
pizza next door or whatever and i was
like you know one of my favorite movies
rob williams you know is my guy but this
movie's theme is divorce like that's a
big part of the story yeah yeah yeah two
weeks after my folks split so i'm like
sitting there holding back tears being
like we couldn't go see [ __ ]
transformers there's a lot less marital
issues in that film because i'm like
nine years old fighting back tears
because it's so [ __ ] real and then
i'm like insert joke about you know you
wouldn't take a you know a woman
wouldn't take her kids after she lost
her husband on a cruise to go see
titanic like whatever there's probably
some version of like that's like taking
a blah blah blah to see this yeah and
then i go but then my what i thought was
kind of a fun take on it and i thought
of you in this because i'm like
end up doing about four or five minutes
on that and then my having a stepmom and
all this and and i go i'm watching this
doubtfire and my
emotions turn from sad to angry because
i'm watching this guy go to great
lengths i'm like dude [ __ ] my dad
like was fine with every other weekend
this [ __ ] he could have dressed
up like a british cleaning lady to see
us five days a week versus once every 12
days yeah yeah exactly
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah
yeah no no no i know it's like but but
what i'm saying is it's like you know
you know so it's like it's what it is is
a hybrid so it's taking a funny premise
that like you could say as a comic yeah
and then like making it personal yes not
everybody has to do that yeah i mean you
know there's no right or wrong way yeah
but like it's how you can like um
you really feel what's happening and
just a lot of the jokes i talk about now
or like the bits i would say not even
jokes is like because of things that
really happen to you yeah can you be too
real do you think oh yes yes yes but so
so you find heightened things you
exaggerate you add things you change
things you know and it's like really
being comfortable with that too because
even though you're a storyteller man you
know this is acting man yeah that's the
thing that people like they don't even
realize they don't you know so stand-up
comedy is like it's just as much acting
as acting you know what i mean we're
putting on a performance you know yeah
and so you play it up or play it down so
it's about finding that level and it's
really hard it's hard to capture that
say like on a special because you know
you have this thing in your head of i'm
filming this big thing and then
sometimes it loses that personality it
loses as a personable personableness so
like i'm telling people when you
sometimes you watch a special and you go
[ __ ] like that wasn't very good or or
i've seen that guy live and he's funnier
it's because of like the heightenedness
of the moment and it's lost that live
comic
thing like so performing in a special
was also a very different art form yeah
you know were these real comments from
your youtube page what do you mean
i saw him live he's funnier
[Laughter]
piece of [ __ ]
by the way you want to talk about acting
after we left cabo and uh devine's
wedding seeing you in that element dude
i
you know i'm sure there's a list of
roles you're like this is i want to play
this at some point but dude guy who runs
resort
i mean because i don't know if you met
the guy who ran the actual resort
uh
he me he hit me up on instagram because
we were uh talking on the very last
night
and we were like what other famous
people been here he's like
an nda i can't really say but go to the
website and um uh he's filipino and uh
i couldn't i couldn't
i don't quite like see you know
[Laughter]
yeah uh and so he was like uh he was
just real charismatic but it was like an
interesting role because this guy was
doing so much and you
the the way that you were just like you
know you have this commanding presence
in most rooms anyway but like whether it
was near the mariachi or at the pool or
down near the water i was like dude i
would like i just saw you in a world
where you wanted it
i mean dude come on well you know what
since we've mentioned it like eight
times so let's just talk about it so uh
adam and i went to adam devine's wedding
yeah adam and adam and adam are very
close friends you guys are closer
friends and even me and adam are close
but yeah just different yeah i mean it
is different but it doesn't matter i'm
just saying i didn't even realize how
close you guys were oh cool yeah and
then that really cemented it for me
because because adam here
was the uh what do you call it the
assistant the officiant of the wedding
you know what i mean so yeah it was cool
he i didn't i honestly didn't even
appreciate the accent he was doing but
it was very
imagine yeah
you know but it was actually it was a
very beautiful wedding in a fantastic
setting yeah it was in cabo at this
i guess it doesn't matter we could say
now right that's bronzing yeah esperanza
resort right there on the water right on
the water now i used to clown
destination weddings you know that's a
that's an old hacky comic bit now you
know about like destination weddings you
know what i mean like everybody
everybody does chris rock's you know
voice you know why are you going to a
destination wedding nobody you know it's
that a lot of comics talk [ __ ] about
people going to destinations yes man but
i'm loud after going to a destination
wedding i'm all about that
on that i'm all in on definition price
is right dude and that's the whole thing
you get to 50 off or whatever it is yeah
we i went extra days because of that you
know two of my favorite uh new favorite
shirts are from the gift shop at that
resort
i was wearing one because it says
there's bronze and i walked you know
what amanda did say you have a spending
problem
did she really i'm an impulse buyer dude
for sure yeah you aren't
going to go to best buy but you know in
all the best ways by the way
my impulse buying and anyone in my
family friend circle will attest to this
it's all for other people it's all for
the
the that's still bad
i guess dude but like and that's your
business and that's your excuse to like
to justify it yeah so you might buy you
might buy four things and one of them's
for you it's a stupid purchase but these
other three it's like well my niece
you know you know there's a new
attachment to the barbie house she had
to have it hilarious i bought them they
they loved mermaids and when they were
you got you you got the solar panels for
the barbie
barbie needed new rims on the uh
ken wanted veneers
and he just got laid off from the app he
was starting no it was uh i got the
mermaid tails uh that were like they
could slip on and pretend to be mermaids
at the because i took them to
arizona got airbnb pool they obsessed
with swimming and i was like they
probably have two more years to think
this is cool so i was like i heard in
that story i heard impulse buying but go
on yeah
dude no excuse but like i'll go to best
buy and see like i rented a pony i got a
i got an airbnb with a pool got a
trainer to teach a pony how to swim
so they could ride the pony in the pool
it was like a pony pool combo thing
but i'll go to best buy and see like a
tom hanks dvd combo pack that's like
turner and hooch apollo 13 big and you
know um
[ __ ] uh
you know uh the furious force gump isn't
in there yeah before you buy that force
comes by itself
dude give forest club a little more
respect than to be in a combo pack it's
always the movies that don't get enough
love and they squish them together so
they go it becomes worth it it's like
last action hero twins and then like
terminator's not in that schwarzenegger
three pack but so i'll see that and i'll
be like i don't need that i also don't
need season six of alf but it's on sale
and it's right next to full house season
two which is also on sale put them
together and you got full alf oh you're
probably a terrible in a walmart
i'm not bad if i'm if i'm stoney bologna
yeah i'll go off the off the rails but
again it's all
dude i mean look it had i not probably
helped out
sister and her fam and pops in the last
four or five years
yeah dude i mean we'd probably be
recording this podcast on my spaceship
oh god so you have boundary issues
yeah for sure yeah and by and by the way
spaceship i just meant like one of those
like airstreams that you've decorated to
look like a spaceship oh but spaceship
money is crazy
yeah
that is something that i want though i
want a uh
not an airstream but i want like a a
guest house
at some point yeah the first time i saw
that was i was uh in uh college out here
and uh a kid in my fraternity was like
hey we're gonna take a couple buses up
to uh my house for a party it's like
we're driving up to this neighborhood
i've never seen any neighborhood like it
he's like oh shaq lives over there
denzel lives over there we go into the
house
oh that's way better yeah and uh it's
one of these like classic uh just huge
la mansions there's like bowls of
cigarettes on every table because every
college kid smoked right he had a room
of guitars that was like 50 guitars all
in their cases three screening rooms the
guest house was bonkers and it was the
first pool guest house i'd seen live in
the flesh that wasn't like on melrose
place or or some uh you know
kim basinger movie um that's very
specific
kim basinger is the first woman i saw
that made me go
you know what i'm saying what movie uh
my stepmother's an alien oh with dan
aykroyd wow
she was unbelievable in that movie
she comes out i think it's like acroid
the music too like did a number like
aykroyd
his face was just like
you could tell how hard he was just by
the face he was making and basically
walks out and like i think barely
wearing anything i remember my mom came
down too it was the first time she came
down and saw me watching something like
that yeah i was like what are you doing
and i was like i don't have a father
this is what happens no i can't remember
what i said but i said something where i
was trying to cover up you made better
choices
this is how i have to learn about the
human body yeah yeah man who who is that
for you who's the first like we're so
off the rails we're gonna get back to
divine's wedding let's go back to it now
yeah let's put a pen in there uh so the
wedding was great officiating there's a
lot of pressures with that i try to make
it funny and heartfelt well let me speak
for you right please it was okay it was
actually
very nice i was very impressed rachel
was crying the whole time
i was teary-eyed i just thought the
whole the setting was beautiful seeing
adam and vulnerable like this yeah chloe
was breathtaking she came walk down the
thing or see herself and all that you
know she looked great everybody was just
you know and it was hot as hell out
there and it didn't even matter and this
guy man just he you it was funny when it
needed to be funny heartfelt when it
needed to be heartfelt uh you got all
the information you needed it was like
it was like very well done to the point
where
i know at least three people said hey
man are you available for our wedding
like that's how good you did yeah like
that really is how good you did it's
like like if you were if you were
running some app
it that it just blew up you know what i
mean like it was like people like you
guys so it was i just want to let you
know give you some more kudos and i told
you there but i want to do it publicly
like this you did that you did a very
great job i love you and you you did you
came right up to me dude with like a
very sincere yeah black handshake and
and uh you know you are you asked for
like a discount for your wedding i
thought was inappropriate right out of
the gate like chloe hadn't even gotten
out of the way yet and you're already
like like move [ __ ] i gotta
get it your [ __ ] is done you know what i
mean
i wanted to do like i said i thought it
would be great if like we just have like
50 of our friends rachel and i just off
to the side waiting and then as soon as
the waiting ends we just go hey can
everybody just kind of
stay seated everybody's exceeding for
like four minutes actually front row can
you guys move because our family needs
to and then uh adam adam adam we slippy
right here adam i don't know if you'd be
in my groomsman but can you pop up here
for the pictures man i think the
magazine's still here
but like but it was like like i said the
setting was great uh you know it was
just fun all the elements
that place was expensive like i don't
know what your room service bill was but
my [ __ ] was i mean we got definitely
some late night eats and some i think
breakfast just everything eating there
at all you go for it did you have the
guy that you could text oh yeah yeah
yeah oh that was crazy oh i literally
was like yo
uh i think it was rodrigo and i was or
um yeah rodrigo and i go uh
i need uh my officiant stuff do you guys
have a printer can i email you something
right away yeah gets emails me back or
text me back i got you
and then it's on my door like 12 minutes
later yeah it's great i mean it was
truly i was doing it for everything i
need towels uh you know of course you
would that was like we ran out of
cleaning
making reservations for me at the
restaurant i was like that's what it's
for it's sort of don't say to me hit us
up for anything yeah and then be like
don't hit us up for this
because then i'm not gonna hit you up
for anything yeah exactly you know what
i mean but we're attentive probably the
most attentive hotel i've ever stated
there was a holiday in express in salem
oregon once
that uh go on that brought me some
silverware when i when i needed some
silverware so that was pretty it was
pretty big i don't think it was as good
as that place but not even close too
that was a joke it was good trying to
open but uh you know and kudos to adam
shout out to adam uh picking a cool spot
yeah having to go it was just good you
know and making that hotel a ton of
money i thought it's a scam like
destination weddings were a scam when i
when i thought about it like especially
for someone high profile like adam you
know so it's like you know he's going to
this place and he's going
you know we're going to have a hundred
guests
the wedding should be free if you bring
in a hundred guests who are gonna spend
minimum of three to four thousand
dollars each group they must have hooked
them up in other areas right like maybe
maybe the way they built the little
stage on the beach or
their room they hooked it up i hope
listen i hope so yeah because what a
what a
the hotel's making so much money off the
people that come to the thing man i did
uh have some jokes that i vetoed and i
want to run one of them by you go ahead
um so you know in trying to find that
balance between like funny and heartfelt
you're also like all right i want to
touch on some of the things that have
happened adam's dad uh dennis you know
has been battling lung cancer and is
pretty much on top of it at this point
um just kind of staying on top of his uh
chemo and radiation but like
miraculously has
uh
crushed pretty much all of it you know
uh which is incredible and so i wanted i
asked adam too when we had kind of a
pre-meeting with he and chloe just to
get more personal info i was already
going to put my own kind of personal
spin on some things but i wanted to hear
some
things that they would say about each
other and it's like i don't want to do
it separately i want to do it together
because it's sweet and that's a sweet
thing for them to yeah because it was
the way they were talking about each
other
that was the yeah that really was the
best part it was cool and so he was and
then they both checked in with me on
their vows just to uh which was just
adorable on adam's front two he ran him
by him just to make sure it was fine and
i'm just like dude perfect like no notes
and and i gave him one little actually
thing that he could do and he did do it
was when he goes
which i thought was uh funny because
when we'd be on two i'd throw him little
you know tags here and there and joke
things and sometimes he would forget
every now and then he'd do one but uh he
goes chloe he goes the first time i
remember we got on to ride bikes in
newport and she said she was really good
at riding a bike and the next thing i
see she runs into a telephone pole and
i'm thinking like all right she knocked
out her two front teeth like let's let's
go like let's go you know get to the
hospital whatever and she was like no
damn it like we're going to finish this
ride like we're hanging out today and
then i told him i go i was like or you
could say like actually she said no
we're going to go we're going to go
and he did it like which was a real
funny like add-on but other than that i
was like you're fine but but they uh i
asked adam i go i want to throw some
love to your dad dennis and and um
everything he's been through and kind of
acknowledged that and i just
it's such a communal family type uh
group and and i think he'll appreciate
that and i just i think it's uh stupid
not to i go but also devil's advocate
maybe
he doesn't want any more attention from
it maybe he just wants to live but i go
i don't know man my instinct is to do it
he goes he goes i think you should and
then he goes maybe there's a way he can
do a joke about it and then he makes a
joke about uh his sister
uh having like uh uh ibs and how it like
came back and i go well maybe that's the
joke i go maybe i go look it's been a
tough year for everyone obviously uh
covid the hurricanes in new orleans with
colby's family having to deal with that
the highs and lows have been uh a
stranger to no one and of course uh the
divine family went through their own um
levels of of uh strife this year and i
think we all know what i'm talking about
i don't even have to say it britney's
ibs come back
you know what
only the people that are close to them
because now
i'm laughing at that joke because i
didn't then because i didn't know yes
even i didn't even know about adam's dad
until now until until yeah to the
wedding whoa yeah it's not like adam was
talking about that yeah you know what i
mean yeah you know because even though
it was like even i've seen his dad and i
you know he was like i was like oh
they're really they're both of them got
in great shape yeah doing stuff but i
didn't know that it was like uh you know
don't worry about this i'm gonna be
honest yeah all about going through some
stuff yeah going through so that's great
you know and i felt like that was
appropriate but you know my question
though was and i kind of feel like from
seeing the wedding because usually the
wedding is all about the bride yeah you
know what i mean as well it should be
right as well as should be and so but i
kind of felt like
chloe was fine with
not necessarily being the sole center of
attention about everything yeah you know
what i mean yeah i got a sense because
because even in your thing i was
thinking to myself oh this is a lot
about adam you know don't forget about
you know i got back to work i know but
yeah oh yeah but but but
not that that's bad you're his friend
yes you know what i'm saying there
should be it'd be wrong if there wasn't
a few more personal attachments you know
that's right but i thought but i thought
she had to have co-signed on that yeah
yeah yeah so i i got a sense that she
was she was very much like let's just
get this done and to their credit like
the uh the other wedding i did was my um
my half brothers and his wife
was like very much like can you send me
word for word what you're going to say
and i was like yeah
should i ever be teasing you about that
and she goes she goes she's like because
i've seen your stand up
do you really think i'm gonna do like
just well that's a testament to what she
thinks about your act
she's like ooh he's gonna okay i need to
get final approval on everything
you ask me just trust and then i go and
then it worked out great and she was
like really surprised and i was just
like which is insulting too a thousand
percent she was like it was great like i
should have just trusted i'm like yeah
and my brother was like not even
sweating it but chloe i'll give her a
lot of credit man she just they were
pumped and they literally
checked in on a few things but she was
just like didn't even quit
didn't really just kind of wanted to
know the order and i kind of just gave
her like it's gonna be this and this and
i'm gonna say some things then this and
the rings and the vows and then that's
it and she was like great and other than
that did not say and i asked like is
there going to be like somebody come up
to read some poetry or somebody going to
play the cello you know there's always
like an extra yeah yeah somebody comes
up like from jacob 3 15 or you know i
don't know from some
you know which is fine too i actually
just went to uh another wedding where
they're both huge movie buffs and for
the ring they had i haven't seen lord of
the rings but they had a guy a character
come up
dressed as not gollum but some
it doesn't even look like uncle fester
from adam's family and he walked up and
they played this like some song from one
of the rings and the guy slowly comes
down the aisle and then he's like what's
that he's like
dude it was actually unbelievable dude i
mean if that's their thing more power it
was and everybody laughed and loved it
hey guys i want to talk to you about our
great sponsor of the show better help
better help man go to betterhelp.com
griffin
um you know the world's still weird and
we're still dealing with stuff and on
top of all the things we're dealing with
again we had this big pandemic and we're
still dealing with it loss of income
not seeing people loss of life i mean
you're dealing with a lot of stuff
therapy will help
better help assess your needs and
they'll match you with a licensed
professional therapist
you connect in a safe private online
environment
it's really great uh the service is
available for clients worldwide you're
gonna get help with a lot of things
these are licensed professionals this is
not self-help they're going to help you
with all the things that we're all
dealing with like depression and stress
and anxiety anger family conflicts
trauma
anything that you share with them is
going to be confidential it's convenient
it's professional and like i always say
therapy you know it's not necessarily
going to help you solve your problems
but it's going to help you understand
why you're feeling the way you feel with
a professional that can recognize
patterns i want you to start living a
happier life today and as a listener
you'll get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor at betterhelp.com
griffin
join over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
that's betterhelp.com griffin for 10 off
your first month
hey what's up guys let's talk about
liquid iv
you're always hearing about how you have
to drink water but you know sometimes
that gets boring water is just like
water it's plain it's bland
um you know but water's
great for you every time you go to the
doctor whatever is going on with you
they always say you got to drink more
water
but look what does liquid iv do
like take it out take it in first thing
in the morning take it before a workout
take it after workout it's daily
hydration it helps you with maintenance
if you have a hangover if you're a
drinker you know the things i love about
liquid iv it tastes great
you know what i mean they got all kinds
of great flavors like lemon lime
strawberry watermelon passion fruit
guava pina colada
you know it's immune support it contains
five essential vitamins more vitamin c
than orange and as much potassium as a
banana
you know it's like
like i say when you're like leaving the
house you just grab one throw it in your
water bottle boom
it's just give you a little change up
and it's great so this company is
donating 4 million servings in response
to covet 19 products are being donated
to hospitals first responders food banks
veterans and active military
liquid iv is out here trying to change
the world look grab your favorite liquid
id flavors nationwide at walmart or
you'll get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use code griffin at
check checkout that's 25 off anything
you order when you get better hydration
today using your promo code griffin at
liquid iv.com
get hydrated
and it tastes good
liquid ivy like if you you it's like
that's why you have people that know you
at the wedding because they know like
they've been to their place and they got
it's unbelievably lord of the rings yeah
you know it's like it's too much it's
too craziness so that people go oh this
is perfect are you people are you a fan
of anything crazy like that or are you
just like man keep it simple keep it
simple the only thing i would want like
if like because we're planning our
wedding yep like
i this thing would be funny for rachel
to like do a fashion show hilarious yeah
like so like she goes up and down the
aisle like four times and the last time
it's the wedding dress that's amazing
have the scholar brothers announce it
i mean that is a great idea just for the
whole wedding party we trying to keep it
simple and like you know you know but
it's like it's just it's just a weird
you know weddings are uh you know are
weird like that
i was disappointed though they didn't
like even at the the final thing that
they didn't do like
you know the best man's speech and all
that kind of stuff and let people say
something about them oh yeah i wanted to
do that you know but i think they did
that on purpose where they were like
okay did you have some words planned
well i wanted to say something about
chloe because i had this chloe story
like one time i was in new york and she
was going to nyu at the time and so we
just linked up you know i was like hey
you want to go movie i'm about to go to
a movie i'm performing she was like yeah
let's go to a movie so when she got to
me when we met in the street she had a
big backpack full of books so i was like
let me get that for you you know she's
ah thank you you know we went to go see
wonder woman all right wonder woman just
came out so we saw it it was great so
when we walking out the theater i
reached to get the backpack and she was
like i got it
so i was like oh you wonder woman now
now you're wonder woman huh
90 minutes of empowerment now you're a
different person yeah you want to do
some sit-ups before we go outside gal
gadot did it i could do it yeah isn't
that who wonder woman is yeah yeah so i
was like and just talk about abbott i
guess like everybody would have been
like but it was you know one of the
things that i really enjoyed about the
wedding is like seeing the guys again
and just like yeah man that's
remembering how great the experience was
to be on workaholics because it was like
we never skipped a beat you know it's
like they're so
it was they're just so genuine and fun
to be around and i really i really
enjoyed that so we took this great
picture the four of us and i just was
like i just was like you know you know i
just go oh yeah this was good times dude
it was really fun to watch you your
energy with them because i i've been
around you so much
uh separately and only
maybe i think i went to the last episode
of workhogs the last taping day i think
you were there i almost believe you were
there just for maybe shooting
um but i've seen you with the guys and
also like at some you know parties and
stuff but it's a real special energy of
like
all you guys interacting and how much
they adore you too which is really cool
yeah i felt that too i i do appreciate
that about that especially blake yeah
you know blake's like like blake is such
a like like a beautiful soul you know
what i mean he's just a good dude to be
around he's like and he's just like a
fun drunk you know what i mean dude he
got he got pissed when i included him in
the uh in the officiant uh portion often
because i was like
you know i said i go we've all been
through a lot this year and i was like i
should say just you know the comic of me
trying to pull something fresh like in
the day of almost like when you go to a
new city and you're like you know let's
say you're in like you know des moines
iowa and you're like yeah boy i just and
they just had a storm you're like thank
god i just got in here before uh you get
that des moines just disappeared and i
was like oh he must pay attention to
what's been happening
where we live and that makes us more
connected now to what he's going to say
so you know i was like so i go it's been
a rough year cove and blah blah blah i
go you know blake got [ __ ] up and
slept outside of his room uh which he
did you know and uh and that got a
little laughing that blake afterwards
like throw me under the bus
he's like had to unclean he's like you
told me you're gonna do the britney ibs
joke and here you are throwing me into
the bus and i was like i go dude i go i
knew you'd be cool with it though he
goes respect yeah yeah they're really
good about uh
that's just that's their thing is there
uh
is there a certain memory that you i'm
always curious when people like that
like there's because you know there
should be the same way there's a friends
reunion a workaholics reunion i told
adam when that thing happened really i
said to him adam you all should do
a workaholics reunion let me moderate
and just do the same thing that they did
you know what i mean like do exactly the
same with tight bottles you know what i
mean you know go to the house you know
and just like do all this it would have
been so funny like they should have done
that but
yeah comedy central is
no they can't because they don't know
how to do funny anymore well they're not
coming central you let somebody
paramount plus is gonna have to do it
right
same thing uh we'll see arguably are you
flooded though with a memory when you
get around that environment and those
people is there like one thing that
comes right back or is it just too much
to cover no i have a lot of great
memories but my my first memory my first
ever memory of of just being a part of
workaholics is and again i've told this
a million times but but it doesn't
matter i don't think i've even said it
that often on this podcast but whatever
i
when i was auditioning yes it's a great
story you know right i told you that
yeah i'm auditioning and you know i went
a day early i don't know why i just read
the thing wrong yeah and i ran into
blake yeah you know and then he's all
like oh you hear from montez that's
tomorrow you know and i'm like playing
it off like we now like to come scout it
out
which is great by the way like even for
anyone even if you don't know the person
like that you know and then he goes he
he always says to me that he goes back
to the writers room and it could be lie
because it's a good first story you know
you don't you know what you don't you
never mess up the truth with a good you
never mess you know a true story with a
good story with the truth right you know
so he goes back and says i think i just
met montez you know but i just never
remember remember meeting him and then
just like the whole audition experience
like just being a part of that audition
experience was like you know i remember
that you know i just remember a lot of
fun times with them i guess one of my
best memories on set though is just like
laughing my ass off was it was this
seance episode
where
we're on we're in a circle you know and
we're doing this seance and adam
is
you know doing nate dog because nate
dogged just died
you know and he's like doing something
about nade dog and jillian is doing
something with him and literally the
whole takeout was laughing wow you know
i just was laughing because they were so
you know but i thought we were
rehearsing yeah are you know they were
shooting i didn't know they were
shooting that's it so on cut adam goes
yeah great choice eric to laugh through
the whole take
i was like oh were we shooting how are
you with that now like when you just did
this movie with ray romano and like it
who else was in it too sebastian yeah
yeah are you
i mean even with sandler like in murder
mystery are you trying to
do
are you like don't [ __ ] break because
it's unpro or are you like no that's a
part of it if they make me laugh no i i
but see i i don't know i just like to be
in the moment of it anyway and that you
know and it's like like oh man murder
mystery what i'm what i'm
what's disappointing is
we originally shot in montreal and we in
the opening of the movie was really him
and i doing this walk and talk down the
street and then we foil a robbery at a
liquor store you know what i mean whoa
and so but the walking talk was the my
first meeting him my first interaction
with him
you know and we it was but that one was
different i'm saying it was originally
longer and
i mean this whole thing you know of
course and then they had to change it
because they were doing something with
jennifer aniston's character setting
that up more so they had to do these
reshoots and then what they did was they
added me to that scene in the table yeah
uh but then they hired a wife and then
so that so i became like i was in the
movie more and it just made more sense
as opposed to like in the original movie
he would have had a dinner with someone
else can you imagine how many people
have gotten like snipped out of things
that could have been like
game changers i mean i i think of i have
a friend that was like in forgetting
sarah marshall and she had two scenes
and they both got cut and i think about
you just saying that with murder mystery
when i was in the lady paul feig
ghostbuster reboot you know i had you
know i got to voice slimer which was
cool but then he let me be the lead
singer of this rock band that was the
first scene in the movie where they
caught a ghost and i had 10 lines and i
got attacked by a ghost i ad-libbed a
bunch we shot for a week at the beacon
theater at the um wang theater in boston
and i'm literally leaving this being
like i'm gonna have a cool [ __ ]
like big middle of the movie ten lines
probably keeping a couple ad-libs boost
that up to 13 lines
and dude i maybe a-line maybe and paul
even hit me up and was like dude like
you know i got sony's notes i got
reitman's notes i got aykroyd's notes
and then my notes he's like this movie's
just like
there's a lot of cooks in the kitchen
and if it's not the four guys
if there's not the four gals like they
especially in that scene they're like
why else you having and i guess why
would you keep
a character like that like having him be
a more prominent part of the scene but
but selfishly for me i'm just like
i told my sixth grade girlfriend that i
was forgetting this so at least he told
you that at least you're not like in the
theater with like your whole family like
okay
okay here it goes well that's what i'm
saying you know that that's happened and
people don't have the luxury of like
getting a heads up but think about the
people that probably have had like who
knows even a game-changing scene where
you're like dude that's going to build
but you and i both know uh as good as
anyone it's like it's never one thing so
even if you do
yeah man it's i don't know it's just
weird like
you know you just got to decide like who
you want to be like what you know
you don't want to be too nervous i mean
like murder mystery is an example of
like you know
you know like you're a fish out of water
like just an overwhelming you you can't
let you get overwhelmed if you think
about what's happening like yeah because
like you know i'm at this table you know
and here's
adam sandler and here's jennifer aniston
you know who are you more nervous to be
in front of you know what i mean like it
was like the whole both of them yeah the
whole thing you know you know equally
and
her more than him because he's a comic
and then once we started like doing the
comic thing it was great who he is it
goes out the window yeah yeah yeah he's
he's very and he's he's such a savant
about movie making too like just every
little thing he knows what's going on
like i remember when we were doing this
walkie-talkie the camera guy was a
certain spot and goes he goes that's not
right man
he was correcting the guy and the guy
was like
then the guy was trying to argue with
him and then he goes
you're right
you know what i mean
said you're right no no the other guy
the guy was like you know what you're
right he just he just had this thing so
you know and i felt like they gave me
the carb launch to like you know you
know all right
we're not married to the lines cool
which was good too so you know and i was
able to like you know and i'm not trying
to like you know
and then she's you know it's like i felt
like you know i was like oh i'm the
light skinned chandler right now you
know what i mean it's like you say that
and she was very gracious and she's fun
to be around and it was just like this
you know funny
thing you know what i mean and so
dude you get to work
and do that much cool [ __ ] that's why i
just like
cannot understand like in the last few
weeks i've been at shows and seeing
comics that are like
doing very well like being like
perturbed by
by such
insane
minimal just concerns that aren't about
that don't concern them you know what
i'm saying and i get we all get to a
point to where you you fill your plate
up with things that that you shouldn't
be right you're trying to eat off the
doesn't matter plate
or doesn't affect me plate and you're
taking bites at things that
that you shouldn't be taking bites of
and uh and there's probably a better
analogy for this but but um
i just when i see it i go it's good to
see that stuff and acknowledge it just
like when you're starting out in comedy
or anything like i used to uh see people
come in and like really massage their
spots you know comics would be like i
gotta go i gotta do like every time be
like i gotta leave early i gotta do
whatever and so i made a mental note of
being like don't [ __ ] be that guy
because i would see how people would
respond to it and i would see how it
would make me feel right to always be
that person so um
i don't know dude it's just there's uh
i know but
yeah but i under okay but what i'm
trying to say is is i i just don't i
everyone has their problems their
concerns or frustrations but like
just the older i get the more deeper i
get into this stuff and try to really
enjoy all of it even auditions whatever
and like i was telling you about this
part i just read for and you'd bust my
balls about because i was like it's just
like you know kind of likable [ __ ]
guy and you're just like oh they [ __ ]
knew they just had the right guy you
know yeah dude you've done that like six
times now i'm just watching some movie i
just watched a movie and then it's like
like even the setup is like here comes
the [ __ ] you know like that's the
setup of the scene camera pants here
comes adam ray hey guys
and i'm like wow that he's that guy the
script camera pans to unlikeable dick
face yeah
yeah yeah all right but let me push back
on something that you said all right um
i know
you know there's a there's a there's a
feeling of being like hey you know why
are you worried about that let things go
but you know but there's also a feeling
that i have of i like to feel things
because feeling emotions
is is how i like to perform
i you know i want you to totally i want
so the only way to feel things though is
you have to actually feel things yes
like you know so i i am always like i
always think of myself as i'm studying
for a joke you know so it's like because
like i know i have jokes about little
minuscule things that might annoy me and
that is like how i'm heightening it on
stage yeah so so sometimes you just need
to
it's just a part of like
it's a part of who you are i get you so
maybe if you're running stale or low on
uh
you know frustrating ammunition you are
almost seeking out things yeah to like
and you find yourself maybe going above
and beyond to try to like yeah yeah yeah
yeah annoyed by something just so you
can feel it just like i could be like oh
okay this is
this is the energy i would need for this
thing or it's like oh i can add this to
that you know that's a [ __ ] weird way
to live i know but i know i get that i
mean a little bit but also a tortured
artist right yeah no i mean it it does
make you more interesting right
versus sitting back and being complacent
and okay with everything right that's
what i'm saying but i don't think you
should be okay with everything i just
think that there also
is
because you're a human being there's no
way to go through life being immune to
uh
to things that bug you but i guess just
what i've seen in the last few weeks are
things that truly
i don't know when something truly is
like out of your control control i'm a
big control what you can control guy so
when people are getting pissed off about
things that truly have nothing to do
with them or that they can't do anything
about i'm just like it's like johnny
depp used to say he's like i don't watch
any uh
i don't watch any of my movies because
what am i supposed to do after it comes
out i can't do anything about it
i saw eric griffin in murder mystery it
was just okay i thought the scene was
supposed to be longer but they put it
down apparently he couldn't remember his
now i got to put johnny depp's face on
thank god i'm not thank god this doesn't
take your shoes off all the work i would
have to do on this episode i got to get
kim bassinger's [ __ ] footage a singer
oh boy let's go to a marshall rug
gallery commercial
by the way he's gonna he oh he's gonna
grab this well he's gonna grab this he's
gonna cut in a marshall rug gallery
commercial put it in and take your shoes
off
did i get some uh comments now for
people being like dude rick's
because we have this and i'm sure you
have it too with him where it's like
he can get very
and it's just his personality
i i don't take offense to how
controlling he can be or how
demonstrative he can be because i just
take it all in stride and i just feel
like it's all joking i don't take any of
it seriously i don't anymore and it's
because oh good i go it's because once
we had a moment him and i had about him
diagnosis his diagnosis
from that moment forward i treated rick
differently oh wow yeah from that moment
forward like i i've
you know
we became super close i mean rick and i
would remember we were in montreal and
he's telling me stories about this and
we're going in and we're both crying you
know what i mean so because it was like
i was like oh man like rick
you know so i i so now i get like when
he when the pandemic hit and rick's
calling me to come over and do his
podcast right
and i could tell in his voice that he
was like he knew he was like oh please
don't be eric right now because i need
you to do some things for me right but
when you come over yeah you know there's
gonna be a long list of he was very
vocal and i went like i get it rick
don't worry about it just tell me what
you want me to do yeah he's like and i
can tell he was like thank you he's like
you know please wash your body before
you you know what i mean it's like i was
like i was accepting of him
pre-diagnosis but i get that yeah i
couldn't
he's a monster
but you know like good cool story though
for you though about rick is uh i was
just in arlington draft house in the
washington area love that and i'm doing
a meet and greet and this this guy comes
up to me and he's like he's very you
know he's like hey man i just want you
to know
that when i saw that episode of you and
rick talking about his diagnosis and how
it changed how you treated him and stuff
like that he was like i was in tears he
said i was bawling because i
was recently diagnosed whoa and it
changed he was like it changed my life
that's great
you know my girl treats me different you
know it was like yeah it was it was like
this thing and you just go damn you know
i i called rick right away too i was
like rick
he wouldn't even let me talk because he
was going into his you know whatever he
was you know i mean i'm just like hey
calm down it's [ __ ] autistic
[Laughter]
he's snapping on the other line you know
he's like wait i gotta go marshall rug
gallery phone voicemail message you know
you know i went to uh his house in uh
cleveland and stayed with i saw this
folks yeah that was a trip man yeah you
were a fan favorite on tyso i mean yeah
i did it's just a uh but like you know
your pod his pod there's a there's a
handful of them that are real uh
real goofy and i like that yeah i mean
it is what it is man you know it's like
we're still doing this thing i think i
think by the way
you just saying it is what it like
there's a certain amount of phrases that
i think people say like user might be it
just felt like we ran into each other 30
years from now at like outside of like a
subway or a tcby and like we didn't
really know how to catch up and have
been too much time what it is
how come we haven't called each other
yeah
it is what it is life's crazy man
well the world man it's just yeah it's
just uh what a year what do you i mean
there's so many just staple statements
you can yeah well that's like but that's
right now i mean you know you know you
think i always feel like like is the
world back to normal no i
i feel like i feel like we're having an
illegal party at our friend's house and
our parent waiting for somebody's parent
to come home you know what i mean what a
great way to put it you know so we're
trying to have a good time but we're
just waiting we're hurrying up we're
waiting for covert to bust in and be
like why are you standing next to each
other
you old enough to be drinking that yeah
why don't you get a mask on you know
it's like it's like oh kovins here
let's get out of here get out of my coat
get out of colvin's room you know so
it's like i feel like that's where we're
at right now so like i'm doing a lot of
shows i'm going out of town i'm doing it
i'm like trying to just milk it huh i'm
trying to get it in while i can before
some you know the spirit airlines uh
frickin
variant comes out and then what are we
gonna do can you imagine if like [ __ ]
really takes a turn and spirit somehow
like thrusts its way to the top of the
food chain where they're just like hey
we still don't serve water but
um the spirit airlines dude
what's their slogan one time i flew and
because you know why you fly spirit
because it says
120 to go to england you know what i
mean
with 42 stops you know you know you're
like you're like oh [ __ ] this is great
yeah and then you're checking in this is
when they get you okay well do you want
to sit in a chair
did you bring your own chair yeah
because that's 250 dollars to sit in a
chair oh you got bags okay well that's
the bag fee
carry-on bag fee
you know you know whatever you like
where do you want to sit in the plane is
that you know this like this was eight
thousand dollars all of a sudden
yeah they don't really how did you do
this to me they're a little ass
backwards what is their slogan though
because like southwest is want to get
away i think delta is um i know what it
is
fly the front spirit airlines is yeah it
is what it is
it's called a callback folks we'll be
right back
marshall rug
[Laughter]
oh man we snapped at the same time he's
definitely gonna use that
[ __ ] dude give him more ammo oh man i
guess you gotta i should call them and
be like you know rick can we get to
marshall gallery i i need the
marshmallow
that's a free ad plug man you know yeah
there's only i mean dude there's been a
only uh a few desperate times when i've
had to go spirit and it's like look
you're right it's like what's funny is
i've done this before but keep going
there's there's a
there's certain things also that you
just go i
i want the plane to like fit a human
body i want the seats to like feel me
started dude like the reclining like i
love that whoever designed the recline
on a seat was like
like it you're here and then every seat
goes to like
there it's like who's ever been like ugh
i want to relax
perfect yeah and it feels like a habit
it feels like the person they used to
decide seat space comfort was brad
williams
you know so he was like this look i'm
comfortable by the way shout out to brad
williams for getting his own bags in the
overhead compartment every time he flies
saw it once live had only heard about it
it is a true feat and people watch him
they try to help him he's like [ __ ]
get off me and uh he [ __ ] catapults
his bag upstairs and gets it in safe and
sound all right i'm gonna see if i can
get rick lastman on the phone great
because i've done this before in the
past i don't know if it'll work oh it
actually did work
hey rick
you're on the pod yeah yeah because i'm
here with
because we just we've done like three
snaps to a marshall rug gallery's
commercial yeah you're welcome dude
this [ __ ] gallery of rugs has never
been so heavily publicized
there it doesn't get that many numbers
oh yeah i know look i would look at him
now oh he thinks he's like he's the he's
the rogan of the young shitty podcast
right there
one frozen character on his podcast you
know what i mean yeah can i tell you
guys though uh i'm in such a good mood i
just woke up from my helix mattress
which you can get oh my god this sounds
like a 1985 stand-up bit no no he's
doing this like he's trying to plug his
thing but
i'm just gonna throw griffin on top of
whatever he says anyway so it's like you
know we all have helix helix mattress
helix sleep do you get two free pillows
with it rick
off all mattress orders hey eric real
quick have you have you been able to get
a word in yet with adam
[Music]
you know what's nice you know what's
nice about doing riffing with griffin
you can hold your drink wherever you
want you don't have to worry about some
[ __ ] tray my shoes are off yeah yeah
yeah
yeah my shoes are on watch your mouth
okay
[Laughter]
i don't know
like an autistic cleaning service
what do you call it some weird girls
come over with asperger's and they're
just all like i need to clean this i
need to clean it
you're like okay i need you to leave
lady i'm not done yet i'm not done yet
i um i recently uh i recently uh i moved
into this place a year ago and i had a
first time i had somebody come help me
clean and they were recommended from a
friend but the process of them coming in
because they need to clean with their
shoes on oh they must have killed
themselves
me cleaning the bottom of their shoes
and apologizing oh god can you imagine
the nightmare to go to rick glassman's
place imagine if rick
imagine it imagine if uh by the way said
set by the way but
i'm fun is the substitute teacher who
got fired on the first day he was
subbing and was getting dragged out of
the school ah give me a break i'm fun
i'm not a teacher i'm a comic rick yeah
with that attitude rick i think you
would be great as a boss for those like
stripper cleaning ladies you know
there's like vans that drive around are
you kidding me oh that he would have to
disinfect them
yeah yeah yeah hey do you guys ever try
kiva chocolates oh are they fantastic
every time i get high i decided to do
that with like
by the way there's gonna come a point
where rick
he does the
in-game ads so frequently that he's not
gonna remember he's not gonna know how
to like
conversate organically yeah yeah without
he's gonna speak in ads yeah well if i
need help i could always go to
betterhelp.com
okay rick and we're done with rick
glassman thanks buddy
rest of your audience mom call rick's
mom she's funnier debbie glassman
call his mom she's got she brings more
to the table
socially and comedically
um
she's got a basement full of perfumes
that was one thing about at rick's house
his mom used to i think work she had a
hoarder or something right
[Laughter]
i mean yes but also she the basement
like got real high went down there it
was like i felt like i was in some like
disney movie like goonies meets like
winnie the pooh
yeah and uh she had uh
she had uh perfumes and ointments
everywhere and she gave me a whole
basket of
i remember i got on the airplane
so high for three days and i get on the
airplane and i have a bag of like
polo sport but then she snuck in like
some kitkats it was just like a glassman
goodie bag you know
but he's the best i love him rick's the
greatest man but but an asperger's
cleaning service is a great idea
let's not skip over gonna get done
there's some places you want to deal
with people like you know it's like
there's some places where it's more
ideal of course to have someone who's
autistic yes and as opposed to like
other where other places would be like
oh this isn't the most ideal situation
i'll deal with it but it is what it is
but like you know i think a cleaning
yeah and like an accountant they got to
be autistic
you know what i mean just to get it done
now were you rick when i first met rick
he was into like uh magic the gathering
you're not into that stuff are you i
know but you like harry potter oh yeah i
love it so you like the wand right here
so you like
okay
you got about two more years left of
calling out your wand placement how dare
you oh rick just texted me like please
uh please uh you know please what plug
my rick takes london youtube show like
get out of here bro
everyone's been to london no one needs
to see it through here no
[ __ ] but before i even plug that
let's go to marshall's rug gallery
i think i actually have that commercial
someplace on my computer if you could do
a travel show though the air griffin
travel show
how about that where where what would be
the premise of it it would have to be
like their griffin travel but it would
be like me traveling meets bar rescue i
love that because i'll be honest dude
and you rick and i doing a travel show
would actually be a phenomenal threesome
of different energies and personalities
and the way we all blend together rick
in general i think because it's like you
you have always having something to be
frustrated about getting both of us
getting frustrated with rick yeah rick
having that no filter no fear going up
to do anything if we say hey go do that
or go say that like we can put him off
on things to go do we never know when
things are serious or if he's doing a
bit at the time yeah you know what i
mean we're setting up a bit like he
can't even just do a bit no he has to
like it's like we're gonna do a bit and
this is how we're gonna do it yeah you
know i know it's mechanical it's very
wait okay so you would go where though
and what would be the pr would it be
like so bar rescue meets yeah so it
would be like i just go to a hotel and
i'm just like what is this
there's pretty in the toilet and i'm not
even trying to help them it's just
you're just calling it out what it is
yeah uh i don't know i mean can't even
travel right now i mean it's like it's
that how do you even do that i mean
there's so many great ideas that you
have to think like how can we do this
within the framework of like are we
going to be wearing masks
with vaccine mandates and like how do
you know what i mean yeah the whole
thing man that is crazy i've definitely
got uh i've got some family members uh
that are like
on my girl's side that are like i just
take my echinacea and i don't need to i
don't need a vaccine and you're just
like i don't think you can come to the
wedding then you know yeah or maybe just
have to wear a mask and get tested i
don't know we'll see well that's i mean
that's i mean that i think that's the
thing i don't i don't know why you know
like when people are have this whole
thing about like well you're not
vaccinated so you can't go anyplace like
it's like well it's not
it's you're telling people to get
vaccinated vaccinated for them yeah so
they can be okay yes this got nothing to
do with you
no because because you could just do the
testing yep so you know like okay we're
gonna test yeah and then so then you
find out they don't have it then you're
good yeah you know it's like just i
don't know the message is getting really
like really weird but i you know how are
those people that are pushing the uh
it's just like nazi germany like the
mask minute and showing your vaccination
card all that's missing i heard this one
they say on the news all that's missing
is the gas chambers and the um
and the uh
you know the gas and the chambers and
i'm just like that's a jewish person it
must be so like like really of course
you're just like oh yeah i remember i
remember how furious the jews were that
they couldn't go to the gyms unless they
showed their [ __ ] backs like
to compare those two is so insane
i know i don't like the people that you
know like when
this message is out there about like you
know be you know like
if you're healthy
yeah you know you don't you know i'm
okay with people that actually are
healthy talking about they don't need to
take the vaccine yeah but it's not those
people that are using those people like
if you're some fat [ __ ] uh you're out of
shape you're you're not taking care of
yourself you're not eating right and all
this stuff i don't want to hear you
talking about being an anti-vaxx
you know what i mean like you're not the
you're not the authority on
you know what i'm saying oh it's like
when i would used to have uh i got
vaccinated right away i got my [ __ ] i
got underground vaccinations i used to
have a when i was single i used to have
a buddy that was recently divorced
trying to give me like dating advice and
i was like bro you are the last guy i
should be going to you know what i'm
saying but not always not not see i
don't know he had a messy divorce he
also was like a bad wing man he was the
type of guy that was like you know he'd
be up in the stands at a football game
and would burst onto the field into the
huddle and be like yo tom brady i got an
idea for a play and it's like bro you've
been out of the game for too long man
this isn't your world anymore yeah i
don't know there's you have to audition
certain people for certain parts of your
life you know what i'm saying if you see
somebody that posts like animal attack
videos on facebook all the time probably
not going to be your guy for current
event perspectives right yeah
yeah yeah if they're if they're sharing
yet they're sharing [ __ ] by email
yeah i don't know it's just there's you
can be you that's why facebook is
dangerous where you can just share too
much
and then you're just like oh dude now
you just talked yourself out of like an
invite to a barbecue man i was you know
speaking of just another subject here
because this just happened and i was
going to talk about it because i wasn't
sure if i was going to have a guest
please but
i i okay so i have a tax person you know
and i hadn't paid the bill with with
them yet but this is a
it was this ongoing thing i'm always
working with them they know i'm gonna
give them the money yeah you know what i
mean so like they switched companies
like they got bought out by another
company so no but i'm still working with
them they send me a bill
you know i paid a bill finally you know
i pay it you know but then i get like
some email from like this
collector
you know
and
so that i owed 29 000 to the company wow
okay and i was like what are you talking
about
how is it that i'm gonna pay more
to get my taxes done than the taxes that
i'm actually gonna have to pay that
makes no sense it makes no sense so i'm
going in you know and the guy you know
and he hits up my manager and agent and
all this stuff too right so i'm like
this is like you know i don't even think
that's legal to do that you know what i
mean like hit you know you know so
anyway they do it they're going through
all this things so i'm getting this
email so then i sent it to my other
financial guy and he's looking at the
email and he he looks at the invoices
and he realizes that they added up all
the invoices instead of realizing that
this is a balance that's pushing forward
so it's like let's say you owe a
thousand in march you're a thousand in
april okay so on the april bill it's
gonna say you owe two thousand because
they put march april this guy would
would be like oh you owe three thousand
because he took the two he took the two
thousand from the april one and the
thousand from march okay so now the
guy's like yo 29 thousand dollars so i'm
like so then the the i finally get a
hold though
i finally get a hold of somebody there
and they're like oh i don't know if
that's we would never do that it sounds
like a scam or whatever whatever right
and i'm like oh
so then i first saw email the guy and i
go hey man read the invoices you know
then he goes he's like he's like oh i
have such a funny back and forth with
this unprofessional [ __ ] i bet okay so
he's like he's like uh
he's like oh oh yeah i see what you're
saying you know
yeah that's like a honest mistake
no ownership yeah he's like uh well they
told us you owe 29 000. i go no they
didn't
you know what i mean all right no they
didn't bro cuz i just spoke to him oh
well let me get back to you on though
what's going on i'm going to look into
this so then i finally talked to the you
know i get an email from the main guy
who doesn't even like acknowledge that
this is messed up he just sends me with
all caps like you don't owe anything you
know what i mean on this chain mail you
know so then i now i write the guy back
i'm like hey buddy
how's the investigation going
you find brian laundry yeah he's like
how's it messing he's like but then he
writes me back all casual he's like oh
you know
it looks like the girls in the the
office put in the wrong amount and it
happens it looks like and i'm like oh
did they yeah oh did the girls in the
office
the girls are you all with he's good
dude you know what i said to him i was
like you know what
i said valiant effort but this was never
going to work you know so then like now
so now i'm like okay it's my agent yeah
so now i'm like so now i'm like hitting
up back to financial the tax people i'm
like so either
i'm i'm getting scammed with my personal
invoices are in the hands of a scammer
or you hired an idiot
which one is which one is it you know
which one is it cause which one makes so
they have to decide which one makes them
look oh man
what's worse or come correct and just be
upfront about it you know what i mean so
then they come back like oh it looks
like our previous company did hire them
and i'm like oh so so let me tell you
then you're telling me you hired some
unprofessional piece of [ __ ] company
yeah so you want you want to uh choose
who you want to this is the email chain
so i showed them the messages and how
the guy wrote the messages to me i'm
like so you hired someone that would do
this
like what if i would have paid them
twenty nine thousand dollars which i
never would have hold and i said and i
actually called it i'm talking to him on
the phone i said dude
you are never going to get this money
from me you understand that right like
i'm never going to use it well i mean
you know there's a lawyer blah blah blah
okay yeah okay lawyer yeah okay go ahead
like this is this don't you know i got
all the proof turns out it's all
nonsense dude they're amount of i'm so
glad that you cop so many scams the
amount of people that gets game i mean
every
two months i feel like there's a 2020
abc news investigation where it's like
showing old people just at home getting
routed for their cash where there's just
like it's either about like right go go
ahead well yeah just people getting
scared i mean
you know [ __ ] it's i mean i don't know
how many unidentified numbers i get
called a week that's what i'm not
talking about it's either about your
it's about the warranty of your car yeah
it's like okay well what could you make
this purchase press two if you didn't
which would just like or drain your bank
account like [ __ ] your mom or it's like
emails about like your your you know
your oh your facebook got hacked or your
instagram is like you're turning off
your instagram i fought for those yeah
you know those are because you feel like
click on this to get to reconnect to the
wi-fi i mean it's basic [ __ ] too yeah
and it's like remember when it used to
be like a really thought-out email from
a nigerian lawyer yeah like what i said
some of those i still get like what
happened to that one you had to like
really go oh okay so i i might have a
million dollars in a bank account and i
have to now they're just going like yeah
man your warranty
they [ __ ] like they used to be prince
in de boise yeah yeah 44 of uh of
nigeria yeah needs to get back to his
family if you can donate six thousand
dollars in yen and you're like all right
well i don't have six thousand yen but
like let me see what that you know
translation is maybe i can get you
something by tomorrow i mean i want to
help the prince but yeah now it's just
like hey it's mike from toyota yeah not
no they didn't even say a company no
they didn't just just your or you need
solar panels on your apartment yeah yeah
yeah you know what i mean man you know i
don't i don't know man
or it's like there's so many kind of
it's either scams or pornography so like
like i can't even deal with snapchat
anymore snapchat is like are you still
on snapchat yeah snapchat is like you
you get like friend requests from uh
lisa something you know and you go on
and they say hey eric blah blah and so
now i know so i'm like okay so he just
hit me with the website you know what
yeah
cause then it just comes up i'm selling
nudes and blah blah blah and i'm just
like what like why are you like is this
how you does this work my thing is like
does this work like are there guys out
there who think oh this girl
wants to meet up with me all i gotta do
is thousand percent go to her web sign
up her 1000 how is that working or just
even like high like you get those bots
that are just
high
and then you don't respond and it's like
and then and then nothing and then
sometimes i've had like why are you
ignoring me and i'm just like wow this
bot's really going hard in the paint oh
i don't think it's a bot sometimes i
think it's a it's a dude and a computer
sending out messages and they're just
like responding on a
on a screen where you're just you know
they're just like you know because like
kick i used to be on kik i got rid of
that one because [ __ ] is that it was a
messaging app for a little while and kik
would be like hey what's your name you
know it was clearly a computer algorithm
so you'd be like hey you know or where
are you now and then it'd be like i
think i met you last night at a
restaurant you like and then so like i
used to then i would get those and then
i started like responding with nonsense
and then and then because they would
respond but still the same they'd still
be on the script of course oh that's
great but you know what i don't want to
be on this anymore you should come to my
private website blah blah blah and i was
like no [ __ ]
oh thanks i would need you to you know
and you're just like i don't know like i
would really like to know is there
anyone out there who has fallen for
the the hooker chick
on
snapchat
have you sent them money like did it
work out yeah like did it work out did
you meet up yeah she had any sort of
like verbal confirmation that she
received
for life
you know did she send you a picture of
like the hat you sent her
you know i mean i just i just don't
understand like like what gets me is
like some of these scams and emails and
calls you know it's like the social
security one that sort of scared
everybody at first for a little bit and
then you start to go like until you if
you have a tax person they tell you like
dude
you can't get anybody on the phone
from the government they're not going to
call you
you know what i mean you start to go oh
yeah
[Laughter]
it's a sad realization did you ever
prank call the like sex hotlines as a
kid did you prank call at all
i know i didn't i just i i was too
nervous because at that time when i was
a kid you know the phone was at home
and there was one room one line in this
one area and then the other line was
next to my mom oh [ __ ] you know so i
didn't want to be all like you know one
time one time i got caught
i was making a choice between calling
a 976 number to hear some you know fake
busty lady yeah or
santa claus
okay yeah one of them was like call
santa and you could talk to santa you
know
and thank god i called santa
because my mom got on mom picked up and
my mom was like and i hung up like oh my
god you know my mom was like eric you
want to talk to santa you know so she
was into it like being like oh he's just
cute he called santa because it would
have been like what are you wearing like
it would have been like you want to
touch my third tit
yeah my mind would have been what are
you doing
that was supposed to be santa
i i pressed the wrong cuz it was mrs
claus yeah
it was nine seven six five five five
four and i dialed a three mom
you know what i mean like even back then
i would have had the like the you know
but
anyways man
we do it i think that we did it
um what a blast i usually like i usually
do this in post but now i'm just like
let's do it let me no i just now i could
just do it like this you know
the outro music
yeah so anyways everybody
uh this has been the great adam ray you
can find him on instagram i'll have all
this information below yeah uh instagram
adam raycomedy
tourdatesadamraycomedy.com
uh i got a cartoon coming out december
10th called crossing swords on hulu and
young rock comes back in february that's
right you're on young rock so let's go
back to shoot more episodes i was only
in two last season i'll be on uh i think
seven or eight episodes this season oh
that's good yeah but they're giving you
top of the show i believe so
seven or eight is yeah i don't think i'm
full on like regular
thanks for being here love you shout out
to rick glassman um make sure you check
out
take your shoes off he's in london
whatever i did it rick and martial rug
gallery
and my podcast about last night which
egriff is uh has been on it many times
and your last appearance was
probably the best app we've had in a
while man there was anytime i get
multiple clips where i'm like there's no
way i can make my whole feed this one
person but dude that was fire so go back
and check that out check that out and uh
but this has been adam ray and he might
be officiating well rachel and i's
wedding because even she was like we got
to have him do it fingers crossed now
we'll see what happens but guys now make
sure you check me out on twitch daily uh
that's on uh you know twitch you get it
and thanks for being here thanks for
listening make sure you share subscribe
check out my other podcast jen the gin
uh
and uh king of sting
uh and thanks for being here and i will
see you
next week bye